so hi and welcome to another episode of
biographics I am your interim host Carl
Smallwood I am drinking out of a Hello
Kitty morgue and today we're talking
about George Reeves and the mysterious
death of Superman
[Music]
in the early hours of June 16th 1959 a
shot run out in Los Angeles Swanky
Benedict Canyon just like that something
that was thought impossible had happened
Superman was dead in case it wasn't the
real Superman but the actor who played
him for over 100 episodes in The
Adventures of Superman television show
George Reeves the police quickly ruled
it a clear suicide and no Thor
investigation was ever conducted into
the death of Mr Reeves many questions
still lingered though multiple people
wanted Reeves dead and there were some
strange elements regarding his demise so
did the actor really kill himself or did
so manage to do the impossible and kill
Superman
George Reeves was born George Kiefer
Brewer on January 5th 1914 in the small
town of woolstock Iowa he was the only
child of Don Brewer and Helen Lesher a
young couple who only got H because
Helen became pregnant with George a
popular origin story for many people
including Superman apparently
surprisingly this didn't last and the
two called it quit just a few months
after their baby was born Helen took
George packed the bags and moved to
Pasadena California there she met a man
named Frank basilo one of the few people
who got rich by making alcohol during
prohibition legally that's it because
his family produced wine for the
Catholic Church anyway Frank and Helen
got married and Frank formerly adopted
George in 1927 the two were close too
close in fact for Helen's liking who was
quite possessive of her son and didn't
like competing for his affection after
15 years Helena Frank divorced and
following a generous settlement Helen
could afford to buy her own home in a
nice neighborhood in Pasadena I would be
her and George with nobody else to cram
their style I'm getting major psycho
vibes from this the film if anyone who's
not seen it as George grew up he
developed into quite a locker he had a
strong six foot two 180 pound frame plus
chiseled good looks not shared by your
host here it's no wonder that his mother
imagine him as the next Hollywood
heartthrock but then George did
something she greatly disapproved of he
took up boxing in high school maybe this
is his way of rebelling against a very
domineering mother he was good at it too
enough to qualify for the Golden Gloves
tournament but Helen was worried that he
would damage his good locks so she
forbade him to take part eventually
George caved to his mother's wishes and
he gave up on the sweet science and in
1935 the 21 year old enrolled to study
acting at Pasadena Community Playhouse
over the next few years George stuck to
the stage appearing in multiple plays
but at the same time grew frustrated as
he saw many of his acting Partners
successfully learning roles on the
Silver Screen this was a frustration he
would become very familiar with over the
course of his life the time would come
for George in 1939 when he finally made
his big screen debut it was a pretty big
one the scuttlebutt around town was that
Hollywood bigwig David O Selznick was
looking to make screen adaptation of the
9 1939 hit novel Gone With the Wind
George thought that he was perfect to
play a Young Southern gentleman he had
the looks and could pull off the accent
apparently the movie's casting director
Max Arno agrees so he signed him on for
the role of Stuart taller on Scarlett
O'Hara suit us everything seemed to be
going George's way but there was one
tiny problem the name George went by the
name George basello after his adoptive
father but Studio exact felt this was a
bit too foreign for 1930s America
especially for an actor was supposed to
embody a southern gentleman so we
decided to change it and thus George
Reeves was born
Reeves didn't exactly have the biggest
role in the movie but we're talking
about Gone With the Wind like every
actor in it affected some degree of
attention and George's turn as Stuart
haliton was enough to get him a contract
with Warner Bros this wasn't a
particularly fruitful relationship
though Reeves appeared in a string of
pretty forgettable movies and usually
playing second or third banana to a more
established star like James Cagney or
Mel Oberon eventually Warner's decided
that maybe degrees wasn't their next big
start and dissolved his contract in
1941. from there he moved to 20th
Century Fox on a short one-year contract
but it's pretty much a repeat of the
same experience Reeves mostly had minor
roles and a handful of movies before the
studio said thanks for coming and chose
not to renew his contract although his
career wasn't exactly skyrocketing right
now there was one significant moment in
his life in 1940 Reeves met and married
young actress named eleanora needles the
pair stayed together for almost a decade
and had no children together that's a
great name for that eleanora needles Mrs
needles Mrs George needles now without a
contract Reese thought it'd be a good
idea to do a bit of freelancing someone
used to freelance
don't recommend this is horrible you
want to focus on Western since those
were a hot ticket item Reeves appeared
in five films featuring a popular cowboy
character named Hopalong Cassidy it's a
sidekick before finally catching the
eyes of Paramount Pictures the first
Studio actually saw some star potential
in him he often him a serious role in a
war drama called so proudly we hail and
Reeves gladly trading his chaps and
Spurs for a military uniform he played
the male lead opposite Claudette Colbert
an impressed Paramount boss enough to
sign a contract with them but just when
it like Reeves's career was firmly on
the upswing it took a massive nose dive
thanks to as you're probably guess from
the dates I've said World War II as he
received his recruitment papers Reeves
got drafted into the army and although
he never saw any actual combat in fact
he was mostly stationed in New York City
as part of the Army Air Force Special
Forces division asking a Broadway play
named win victory that was meant to
boost morale and raise money for the
Army emergency relief fund he eventually
got transferred to the motion picture
unit where he made training recruitment
films as well as one on venereal
diseases title sex hygiene and we've all
got to start somewhere and mind turns to
Jonathan Banks
um you know Mike from Breaking Bad who
cut his teeth appearing in a PSA where
he thought that a woman being on her
period would make her Bowl better that's
that's that's not hyperbole
admittedly though he had a pretty good
sense of humor about it and he played
like a John Oliver bit where he uh
reprized his role and made fun of his uh
his past self anyway once the war was
over Reeves discovered just how thick or
Hollywood could be when your name is not
up in lights at the Marquee public tends
to forget you pretty fast there was a
glimmer of hope for him it came in one
of tinseltown's next leading Stars
following so proudly with hail had more
or less been extinguished when Reeves
got back home he was shocked to discover
that his biggest supporter at Paramount
the director producer so proudly hail
Mark sandrich had died suddenly sandrik
was the man who promised that he was
going to turn George Reeves into a big
star and it seemed that everyone else at
the studio was a bit more lukewarm by
its potential as a leading man it was
not like George actually fought in the
War like fellow actors such as Jimmy
Stewart or Clark Gable all he did was a
stage play in New York and talk about
like venereal diseases so he couldn't
exactly play The Returning hero card to
help him get any roles with Hollywood
not exactly busting down his door he's
traveled to New York where he appeared
in a bunch of radio dramas he wasn't
until 1947 he got to appear in a film
again that was only a cameo in variety
girl in 1948 it was a bit more fruitful
for Reeves with several more movie roles
but these were all poorly paid small
roles in B moves had no chance of
resurrecting his dwindling career and
things were about to get even worse in
1949 when George's professional life
reaches nadir when he started in a 15
chapter Serial Set in Arthurian times
titled The Adventures of Sir Galahad the
sets were cheap and reused from old
westerns even though the action was
supposed to take place in medieval
England the writing was terrible the
acting was worse and even for a matinee
show this was seen as scraping the
bottom of the barrel for any actor but
life wasn't done kicking Reese in the
balls just yet because his personal life
wasn't going so hot either and his wife
divorced him in 1949 fed up with the
insecure life of a struggling actor
instead preferred to get hitched to a
rich attorney but then George received
the shock of his life one Damon's
approached by a middle-aged man who
introduced himself as Don Brewer AKA his
biological father the reason this was
such a surprise for Reeves was that his
mother had always told him that his
father had committed suicide and this
new revelation caused a rift between the
two that would take years to heal the
things to put it diplomatically were not
looking great for George Reeves at the
time but then fate threw him a life
preserver a life preserver wearing red
and blue spandex
all right
all throughout the 1940s there was a
radio series titled The Adventures of
Superman which ran for over 2 000
episodes it wasn't exactly surprising
that in 1951 Hollywood execs thought it
might work in this new and crazy medium
called television there'd also been a
film serial in 1948 starring Kirk Allen
and Superman so alas despite what some
might claim George Reeves was not the
first live-action Superbad though he was
the first person to Don the mantle for
TV speaking of Reeves there is a popular
myth that states that he got the job
after the show's producers spotted him
on Muscle Beach in Venice California
which isn't true although it is true
that producers Scouts are bodybuilders
for the wrong of Superman eventually
they decided that good looks and acting
ability though were more important fake
rubber muscles were good enough they
actually considered over 200 actors for
the role but producer writer Robert
Maxwell knew he had found the Man of
Steel the moment Reeves walked through
the door apparently it was the jaw that
did it for them as a little bonus fact
about how Reeves got the role like he
was as mentioned earlier in the video
like very like you know well built and
toned and to establish that he could
pull off the look of Superman you know
the Spandex and underway over them he
had to strip down to his underwear for
producers and then proceeded to carry
one of them up a flight of stairs like a
fireman to show that he had like no the
physical strength um to portray the Man
of Steel so now Reeves had the wrong but
he wasn't sure that he really wanted it
television had only really starts to
take off in American houses after World
War II by many actors George included it
was still seen as the place where
careers went to die but just like
galahari do you assume this would be
some crappy low budget kid stuff that
nobody would actually see so he
swallowed his pride and as many actors
have done in the past and since Did It
For The Money the series actually
started off with a one-hour feature
titled Superman and the mole man which
act as a pilot for the show itself after
that production immediately started on
the rest of the series we've got a shot
down soon after due to lack of Interest
pretty much what Reeves expected to
happen but then someone came to the
rescue and it wasn't a bird or a plane
but Kellogg's the serial company as it
turns out they had sponsored the
adventure of Superman radio serial and
wants to do the same for the television
show and am I the only one who finds it
amusing that the people who made cereal
sponsored a radio cereal I know it's
cereal with a c and cereal with an S but
that's some good pun work right there it
wasn't until February 1953 however that
the events of Superman actually
premiered on American TV into the shock
of almost everybody involved George
included became a success almost
immediately overnight George Reeves
became Superman to many Americans much
to his own displeasure he'd still hoping
that the TV show would be nothing but
quick paycheck and maybe a springboard
is some better movie roles for him
because the movies would still wear his
heart Lane but the truth is that in 1953
the same year Superman came out we got
cast in Major Motion Pictures the war
drama From Here to Eternity he was his
biggest movie role since so proudly with
hail and Reeves hoped that maybe a
career Resurrection was on the horizon
but then his heart was crushed during a
sneak preview as Reeves appeared on
screen everyone in the audience started
shouting Superman Superman there's
Superman and they filled out their
preview cards and wrote how cool it was
to see Superman in the movie The film's
Producers were not happy about the
character of Superman taking away the
spotlight especially since Reeves was a
minor role in the movie so in the end
they cut it completely Reeves only had a
single film role after this after that
he realigned himself the fact that for
better or worse he was Superman
[Music]
the Superman TV show went on for sixth
season and well over a hundred episodes
on top of that reasons paid for all
sorts of appearances as the man of steel
so he was earning a pretty decent
paycheck but still nothing compared to
the big stars of Hollywood he still felt
like he was wasting his life at the same
time realized that nothing better would
probably come along especially since he
was on his mid-40s by the time the
series had ended Reeves's private life
was decidedly murkier than a squeaky
clean Public Image he projected as
Superman ever since 1951 Reeves had
maintained a secret relationship with an
older and more importantly married woman
named Tony Mannix a former show girl and
by secret we mean that everyone in
Hollywood knew about it since the couple
was not exactly shy about parading
around together all kinds of social
events but the relationship was never
mentioned in public our respect and fear
for Tony's husband Eddie Mannix
ostensibly Eddie Mannix was a film
executor MGM Studios but in reality he
was known as a fixer a thug who uses
connections and gangster tactics keep
starting line and the indiscretions and
other newspapers at best the man helps
silence cases of public drunkenness
drug boss Affairs the occasional DUI and
maybe arranged for a few secret
abortions at worst he had been accused
of covering up rapes about assaults and
perhaps even murder in other words
Mannix was known to be a man not to be
messed with but Reeves was allegedly in
the clear with him he seems that Eddie
Mannix knew of his wife's relationship
with the actor and was fine with it as
long as he too was allowed to have his
own Affairs and Tony Mannix was by no
means an informatable woman she knew how
to get what she wanted thanks in part to
her husband she had all sorts of power
and the money to get what she wanted so
when what she wanted was a boy toy to
pray around town with she knew exactly
what she had to do to keep him she
bought Reeves at fancy house she also
bought him cars and paid for most of his
bills they were all in Tony's name so of
course she basically owned him the
strategy worked for around eight years
well eventually Reeves fell in love with
another woman and wanted to marry again
something which he couldn't do with Tony
Maddox her name was Lenore lemon a
socialite from New York who was
ostensibly just as possessive jealous
and domineering as Tony Mannix and
George's mother he's seen that Reeves
and we ever knew one type of woman in
1958 reevesboro caught with Tony Mannix
and started seeing Lenore lemon as you
might expect the latter did not take it
well but didn't kick Reeves out of his
Helm which technically belonged to her
instead she began harassing the new
couple probably thinking that she could
still manipulate our coerced George into
coming back instead he took out a
restraining order against her on June 19
1959 George and Leonardo were supposed
to get married in Mexico and then leave
on their honeymoon to Europe this never
happened three days earlier the couple
were having drinks with a few people
over at their house in the wheat hours
of the morning reason upstairs and
retired to the bedroom allegedly that's
when Lenore told the rest of the group
that George was possibly going there to
shoot himself everyone even thought it
was a joke I was too drunk to care
because nobody moved and then a shot
rang out
heard the shot Lenore asked one of the
guests neighbor William Bliss to go
upstairs and check on Reeves blistered
as requested and upon entering the
bedroom he saw the body of the actor
lying naked in a pool of blood with a 30
caliber Luger between his feet you know
went downstairs and he formed the rest
of the party that Reeves had died after
the police were called two LAPD officers
arrived and inspected the scene they
found that Reeves had been shot in the
temple in an awkward trajectory with the
bullet getting lodged in the ceiling the
spent casing was beneath his corpse for
the non-csi aficionados out there this
meant that it got ejected and landed on
the bed before the body which was
unusual but not conclusive by itself
the cops did their due diligence and
interviewed everybody downstairs they
were all drunk but gave more or less the
same story then all said that Reeves had
been depressed or his dwindling career
and his new money troubles and now they
didn't have Tony Mannix as a sugar mama
anymore for the police this made perfect
sense and open a Showcase of suicide if
there ever was one you know I was
sensitive and emotional these active
types can be to the point they didn't
even call in the crying Squad to take
photographs of dust for fingerprints
they just called The Coroner and went on
their way at the medical examiners laugh
the coroner gave the body a whatsoever
to make sure there were no other signs
of violence he didn't find any for
anyone curious and since the police
ruled it an unsuspicious death he had no
reason to perform an internal
examination he too thoughts the
straightforward case of suicide so he
washed the body and embalmed it later it
was sometimes reported that Reeves did
have bruises on his chest and face but
this has never been thoroughly
corroborated by other sources the first
person suspect that not everything was
on the level was George's mother Helen
as soon as she arrived in Los Angeles
she hired a private detective agencies
to conduct their own investigation like
many of George's close friends she
refused to believe that he could commit
suicide and although the private eyes
did did find weird things about Reese's
death it was never enough to get the
case reopened so therefore we are left
with nothing but speculation regarding
any alternative outcomes to the death of
Superman but since you've got time let's
just delve into the conspiracy shall we
so one plausible scenario implicates his
wife to be Lenore lemon on the 19
question she waited about 45 minutes
after George's deaths called the police
this could have had Sinister motive but
a more plausible explanation is that the
people in the house might just sober up
since they were all pretty wasted after
all I would three other people who
weren't close to Lenore helper get away
with murder why exactly she'd want
George dead we can't say but she did
sneak into the house the following day
breaking the police seal on the door she
was caught red-handed by the executor of
Reeves estate art Weissman who was among
those convinced that his friend did not
kill himself it seems that Lenore went
there to steal four thousand dollars in
Travelers checks out of that she hired
an expensive lawyer went back to New
York and stayed there washing her hands
at the whole Affair what about the more
obvious and sexier possibility that
reads was done in by Tony and Eddie
Mannix I mean of all the people involved
in the story Eddie Mannix would have
been the most likely to arrange a hit on
an actor since he had alleged ties to
the mop but would he do that to avenge
the hurt pride of his wife it certainly
would have been a unique case where a
man killed his wife's new lover but not
because she slept with her but because
he stopped sleeping with her and the one
suggested piece of evidence in this
direction comes courtesy of Phyllis
Celts the actress who played Lois Lane
in the Superman TV show decades after
the fact she said that she'd received a
phone call from Tony Mannix around 4 30
in the morning on the day of Reese's
death Tony was hysterical and
hyperventilating ranting about how
George had been murdered well this was
way before the news had been made public
so how could she have known
like to steal metabloid story showed
that Tony Mannix confessing their
deathbeds having Reeves killed and as
conclusive as that might all sound it
has been dismissed as pure hearsay after
all we already knew that Tony Mannix had
a motive but it doesn't explain how the
killer got in did the deed and then got
out without being seen or why they
undress for that matter as a result the
question of Reese's death has no
concrete answer and will probably
continue to puzzle Fascinate and
frustrate crime Buffs for years to come
until then we can only accept the
official series of events which states
the actor was depressed and killed
himself thus bringing a Inglorious and
ignominious end to the end of
television's original Superman
so cheers everyone for tuning into this
episode of biographics I've been your
interim host Carol Smallwood uh thank
you to top tens for allowing me to step
in if you recognize my face from
anywhere and it's not from the other
videos that we've been making for
um biographics the sister channels
Geographics top tens it's likely from
fact fiend which you can find link below
which is the channel I started many
years ago and yeah if you like this
video like let us know in the comments
leave a like subscribe all that good
stuff and as always have the day you all
deserve cheers
[Music]